[Música]
reunimos a siete adolescentes soy
adolescente soy adolescente suyo
violación que soy adolescente soy
adolescente soy adolescente soy
adolescente
hay un impostor entre ellos si el grupo
lo descubre se repartirá en el premio
pero si el impostor sobrevive se quedará
con todo el dinero
pero van a la universidad no sé a cuál
van pasadena siri y tú no estoy en una
muchos creen que a los 18 ya debes ir a
la universidad o dejar la casa de tus
padres pero hay muchas personas de
nuestra edad o incluso mayores que aún
viven con sus padres y es algo normal
escuchan música cuáles son sus cantantes
me gustan yo haría una grande
los jonas brothers volvieron quemaduras
estás cursando los 106
demonios
la verdad es que se estaba esforzando
demasiado
quien usa tacones por eso debe tener
unos 26
yo me dejé llevar por mi instinto
buena suerte a todos
creo que fui la primera en ser eliminada
por mi estilo de vestir luzco bastante
mayor de lo que soy pregunta rápida
votaron por hillary clinton en las
últimas elecciones voté yo tampoco lo
suficientemente
descuida
bueno yo tenía 16 años tengo una
pregunta que les gusta hacer en su
tiempo libre a mí me gusta patinar
genial videojuegos con mis amigos yo
también me gustan mucho los videojuegos
también tengo un canal de youtube grave
hace poco terminé victoria seria
sí
[Risas]
youtube
muchos youtube
sigues en youtube
me gusta mirando así es grandioso así
a ver qué bebida alcohólica les gusta
díganme cuando empezaron la secundaria
no recuerdo 2014 a finales del 2013 creo
que en 2012 diablos
i
es muy alto y usa zapatillas así que
pensé debe de estar muy cansado de
caminar de un trabajo al otro
vote por él porque no hablaba mucho
hay un triple empate
entre
jack link y brand en solo cuentan con 30
segundos para intentar convencer al
grupo
vaya bueno obviamente no soy un adulto
pero no sé por qué lo pienso y no sé qué
no sé qué decir para que me creen me
gustan muchas cosas de adolescentes como
one direction aunque se hayan separado
son geniales y veo muchos programas para
niños es la verdad soy un adolescente
común mi cuarto siempre está desordenado
mi madre me grita me la pasó hablando
con mi novia y jugando videojuegos la
verdad no sé si darle importancia sólo
soy un simple adolescente
demonios adiós buena suerte pensé que
llegaría la última ronda quizás es
porque luzco muy joven no lo sé qué les
parece si hablamos sobre lo difícil de
ser adolescente para mí es no tener
dinero
yo estoy aquí creo que si te esfuerzas
excesivamente es porque hay algo que
tratas de
ocultar bien que me daba esa impresión
los 18 o 19 años somos casi adultos es
pero no ganamos lo suficiente si los
problemas de esta edad mi dinero viene
de nunca tengo dinero
tanto
dinero
pero tengo una beca financiada por bill
gates
tarjeta
cinco meses cinco no lo digas en voz
alta la verdad es que todas las veces
que intenté obtenerla mis ahorros eran
menores a 200 dólares
por eso es que aún no tengo una tarjeta
de crédito o cual suban favorito
hoy s cuales es la broma del pollo fue
muy divertido no se me ocurre ninguno
bien recuerdan uno en el que están en la
tienda de comestibles y se comienzan a
lanzar cosas
demonios
los
chicos tienen twitter oigan chicos yo no
lo está entre las cosas que me gusta
andrew ya ni me dijeron que no votará
por el hijo del presidente aunque sea
saben quién es el senador espero yo
arnold schwarzenegger
lo decía bueno opinó que se acabó el
tiempo
[Música]
adiós eres el mejor creación en el
blanco más fácil creo que los demás
pensaban igual y por eso lo hice
levanten la mano si aún tienen dudas si
quieren continuar con el juego
chica 3 si 21 hagámoslo ya casi o mejor
sobre bailes virales hablemos de la
juventud
todos conocen el baile están quiles
hagamos lo que
saben cuáles
lo haría yo lo hago pero no quiero que
aparezca en internet
esto
es del año pasado y así no lo conocía
también puedo hacer esto y
más famoso cuando estaba en primaria
william o
a una reconquista
pregunta difícil spotify hoy es para ti
fútbol tiempo que rápido ya que sí
[Música]
lo siento lágrimas la verdad es que no
quería hablar tanto como lo hice pero se
estaban desviando de los temas
importantes y así nunca encontraríamos
al impostor así que supongo que hablar
tanto me jugó una mala pasada pero bueno
da igual
levanten la mano si aún tienen dudas si
quieren continuar con el juego
hagámoslo
si la luz se pone verde es porque
eliminaron al impostor pero si se pone
rojas porque sigue en la caja y
perdieron
no no soy yo confieso también tengo 18
años créanme por favor el impostor dar
un paso al frente
bien
dinos cuántos años tienes cuantos creen
21 21 tengo 25